at the same time he was amassing wealth
fame and power i believe i can fly
our kelly was sexually abusing children
but even after being handed a 30-year
sentence little remorse
does he recognize any extent that his
behavior was wrong
as as i said in court mr kelly has
regrets but no he's not guilty of the
charges for which he's been convicted
earlier the singer was forced to sit and
listen as victims described him as
disgusting and despicable one told the
court kelly was a pied piper who lured
children with his money and celebrity
judge ann donnelly said there were few
crimes more serious than serial rape and
abuse over many years but the most
troubling aspect of this case is the
fact that r kelly got away with it for
years he was a predator operating in
plain sight and it seemed to be an open
secret that he was a sexual abuser
for those whose lives he damaged relief
i stand here very proud
of my judicial system
very proud of my fellow survivors
and very pleased with the outcome 30
years did he do this and 30 years is
what he got why'd it take the police so
long why does it take the police so long
you frustrate it took so long for you to
get justice i can't speak to why it
takes anyone the amount of time that it
takes but they've done their homework
they've presented their case
and now we have justice in our judicial
system
r kelly now faces a further trial for
child pornography offences which he
denies the singer will be in his mid-80s
before he's considered for release joe
pike sky news new york